Halloween's now done we now must look
forward to the classy movies of
Christmas a very Harold & Kumar
Christmas in 3d and since I've forgotten
to talk about the 3d and some of the 3d
movies I'll tell you about the 3d how
was the 3d in this movie alright now on
to the movie alright so admittedly I've
never seen any of the Harold and Kumar
movies not that I thought they'd be bad
I just haven't seen them they came out
in a time I think when I worked retail
and I was miserable so going into this
movie fresh I don't know anything about
it and so in a very Harold & Kumar
Christmas Harold settled down he has a
wife it's a pretty hot chick whose dad
is Danny Trejo which is scary as [ __ ]
and her family is coming over for
Christmas he really wants to make a good
impression and after that the
shenanigans ensue now we have Kumar
which is really funny cuz that dude was
in the show house and he left the show
house cuz he was like oh I want to work
in the White House for Obama and now
he's in this movie so do you think
Obama's like that Kumar he's my guy
doubt it or hey maybe he is in which
case that is awesome so Kumar hasn't
settled down he's a big manchild he
smokes a lot of weed and the two
reconnect for Christmas or at least one
movie involving Christmas so at first in
this movie there are a lot of weed jokes
a lot of drug jokes and I was like
alright those can be funny but I hope
the movie has something else a lot of 3d
weed smoke also that was actually kind
of impressive and lo and behold this
movie is surprisingly hilarious I mean I
went into this movie going okay this
might be stupid as hell and I'm not
saying it's the smartest movie ever I'm
just saying the movie had me laughing to
tears you know what I always say yeah
the movie was funny but there was no
scene that actually made me laugh out
loud really hard this movie had like two
or three scenes that did that for me in
which case I gotta give the movie props
it's a comedy it made me laugh it did
its job well that's all I can ask for in
a comedy just make me laugh
some of the jokes I was like alright
that was just cheap others almost like I
did not expect that there are a couple
of dick shots in the movie to which I
mean I'm just addressing it because it
almost seems like movies these days like
alright no matter what happens we have
to find a way to actually be able to
show a dick on the screen in 3d now we
have to twice and they do one of the
funniest segments in the movie was the
Neil Patrick Harris segment when NPH was
on screen I was laughing my ass off that
dudes really hilarious dude he's a
talented actor go NPH what an mph
t-shirt now yeah I saw the one an mph
t-shirt and I went like this I'm
straight I swear and I like the fact
that the movies in 3d but it's almost
like they make fun of the fact that it's
in 3d and
in general I don't know if it was one of
those things for the studios like
alright it has to be in 3d because
that's you know that's a big moneymaker
right now the writers were like alright
well we're gonna make fun of that fact
then I have no idea but I thought it was
awesome is this movie for everybody no
not at all it's not for everybody if
you're easily offended by drug jokes
crudeness or laughing really hard you
might not want to watch it however if
that doesn't bother you this is the
funniest Christmas movie I've seen in a
long time I mean for Christmas you
should bring over the family bring over
grandma watch it they'll hate it but
you'll have your own private joke or
maybe grandma I'll like it in which case
that is the coolest grandma ever get her
something nice so in the end some of the
jokes were kind of cheap I was like that
took no thought whatsoever other jokes I
was like that is the most hilarious
segment I've seen all year I laughed I
cried - crying and the movie has machete
and Santa Claus who gets shot in the
face a movie for me is win so honestly I
would say I would buy this movie on
blu-ray I want to live in a world where
my Christmas blu-ray collection consists
of a Christmas story Christmas vacation
and Harold and Kumar Christmas because
that would be a great world so what's
your favorite Christmas or holiday movie
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]
you
[Music]